blad Smiths welcome to the forge I'm
sure that before you came to this Forge
you practi making a signature blade in
your signature style but that's not what
we're going to be doing
today on your anvils in front of you is
a piece of W1 steel your first round
challenge is to use that steel to forge
the kind of knife Jason Knight is known
for the famous kri good luck blade
Smiths your three-hour Forge time
starts now you get a piece of metal the
size of a soup can it takes an awful
long time for the heat to travel from
the outside to the inside I think this
has been the biggest Billet of Steel
we've given any of our
contestants I think some of my strengths
coming into the forge are what I know
about metalurgy metal is something I
think about I work out in my sleep my
wife says that I have an unnatural
relationship with
metal Larry is the first one of our
Smiths to actually take steel over to a
machine it just doesn't seem like it's
hot enough I wouldn't Forge that
temperature everything goes faster when
you have enough heat trying to get a
large block of of a tool steel up to
heat to be able to move that into a
Billet is a challenge so the first thing
I want to do is draw this material out
so I can start to get my profile worked
out look at the difference between Brock
steel and Larry steel over here cold
gray lump versus bright orange
brilliance I'm working with this thing
and it's
ugly but until I have more heat out of
this Forge I can't make the steel do
what I want so I put some more fire
brick on top of the forge trying to
insulate the forge to keep my heat in
never made a kri but making a kri out of
a soup can that's a whole another bottle
wax I need another 3/4 in in the belly
of my blade to reach the minimum so I
I've got to stretch it out quite a bit
Bing Bing b b b b he can swing a hammer
no doubt I need to get this to the right
parameter so I don't get eliminated for
something foolish you know what Brock
blade actually looks like a
CER that's cuz he's got the Elven boots
of knife making gosh I know man I got to
get those woo think I need to work it
just a little bit more and I'll be done
man that looks great I've got the belly
of the the blade pulled out so I should
be safe on the parameters I'm coming up
on my quench and I've never worked with
W1 so I'm really starting to get psyched
out on how I need to deal with this no
do it what are you doing all right Brock
just did an edge quench in
water it's pretty
ballsy I hear a nice Tink sound which is
not
good I'm starting to panic it's
cracked all I can do at this point is
clean it up some and hope it's
enough this could be it I hope Brock
saves the princess in this
episode there we go Paige is in the
quench oh man that thing was great red
that was a hot holy
smokes we got a quench over there with
Larry 10 9 8 7 6 5 4 3 2 1 blade Smith
shut down your machines your forging
time is
over this is the strength test I'll be
testing the strength and durability of
your edges by chopping into these trees
three times this is not about what your
blades do to these trees it's about what
the trees do to your blades a palm tree
is not easy to chop through on the best
of days it's designed to roll an edge
Larry you ready always ready and that's
why I made an edge that would be able to
handle a problem like these palm trees
very difficult to hold on to this knife
I just don't have good leverage there is
no Edge damage oh wait a minute there is
Edge damage right
there doesn't surprise me you still have
essentially a flat bar of Steel and the
edge is only right here that's a little
shocking to me but all I can do is give
it to the god and see what
happens all right Brock you ready yeah
I'm pretty sure that I got all the
cracks out but if I didn't it could be a
fatal flaw in this
testing Brock I like the way you got rid
of the cracks I'm impressed that you
were able to pull that off it's thin
enough to cut it's sharp uh we didn't
get any Edge deformation here well done
paig you ready kind of got to be I'm
feeling all sorts of nervous cuz I
didn't have time to put what I consider
a good Edge on the
blade well Paige your handle is
comfortable but it's a little round here
it makes it a little more difficult to
control however your blade cut deeply
into the wood and your Edge has no
damage to it well done I'm doing good
but there's still a rope next up is the
sharpness test and for that I'll be
turning over to Doug to test the edge
retention of your weapon I will try to
cut through this 2-in rope by slashing
it up to three times seeing my blade in
Doug's hand makes me happy he's a fellow
martial artist and I was kind of waiting
for that
moment
you definitely have a beast here making
it even harder to control on recovery
power without control is useless but
your blade will
cut thank Brock you're next ready I'm a
bit nervous at this point because my
Edge is probably not as refined as my
[Music]
competitors
Brock what I like about the feel of your
handle is that it's easy to index and
know where exactly The Cutting Edge is
remember it's not about cutting all the
way through the Rope but it's also about
the edge retention of your weapon it's
not very refined but overall it's got a
good feel to it your blade will cut
Paige your turn you ready yes
sir
well Paige your handle feels comfortable
in the hand your blade is actually light
and balanced so it's easy in recovery
your blade is sharp enough to cut good
job blade Smiths it's time for one of
you to leave the
forge Larry your blade did not make the
cut Larry your hand was very large and
it made for an unwieldy feel while using
your blade but in the end your blade was
the only one that developed any kind of
edge damage that's why we're letting you
go well Larry please surrender your
weapon I feel it was an extremely close
competition I made a beast of a blade
for a viking of a person I definitely
achieved the goal putting myself out
there and challenging myself life
without challenge is boring if we don't
rise up and meet life then we're not
[Music]
living